welcome back to las vegas now we are
celebrating 17 years of triple george
grill at downtown grand hotel and casino
all month long executive chef casey
faisal is here to show us how and also
general manager george over there george
are you the george i am adrian
are you the george
welcome guys okay we've got a really fun
month planned for everybody especially
with the name
george or jorge correct any version of
that georgia georgia georgina oh bro
okay yeah we're accepting all as long as
they have a valid idea to show their
first name is george okay okay some
version of it i love that that is such a
that is such a fun concept now do we do
any does anyone else get
in on the specials at all or is it
really strictly
the only the george
georgina georgettes
fine but we do have
something available for anyone else
to celebrate the month right because
it's obviously a huge anniversary here
17 years of success and great food what
are people getting with these specials
all month
so uh for lunch one george um
we'll get what our george lunch special
it's uh
single george single jewelry okay single
george
lunch yeah
single george so we have we have three
lunch versions and three dinner versions
the george single will get the half
sandwich
selection of potato chips
sweet potatoes
truffle
fries or regular fries
dessert and then a choice of super salad
this is great i love this is just like
the perfect meal all right who is double
george what's double george getting so
they will get
each well they'll each get one so we're
giving away two for lunch for each one
and then the third one in addition to
the george lunch
we'll start them off with a bottled
water sparkling or steel and
a choice of an appetizer a crab cake
calamari or
uh
[Music]
let's just say let's just say i wish my
name was george okay or georgia or
georgia so let's move on now to casey um
we're talking tomahawk steak
this is the triple george special and
we
we don't do it light around here
i mean we are we are we are known for
our steaks
uh you know we've had this big boy
cooking for about uh an hour now
are we cutting it are we coming
we don't have a lot of time so let's get
let's get it cut so yeah it's a nice
angus steak we're uh
you know 64 ounces oh my gosh
wow
and
you know we just
[Music]
and while he's slicing so for dinner
the three georges get
three martinis three
classics and they get each one of the
accompaniments of crab cake calamari and
shrimp cocktail
and they get to spit this 64-ounce
beauty dang
i'm jealous okay now also george you
know how do people do they need to make
a reservation should they just come
through how does it work what's the best
way to celebrate it's always recommended
okay um
702-384-2761
write the number down
we're located on 201 3rd street and
we're situated in between mom museum and
the fremont street experience okay right
in the middle of the block across from
downtown grand that is incredible
george's you guys are in for a treat
jorge's georgettes whoever can come on
down all month long of august and we'll
be right back